avanzamos en los temas de directo
América pasamos a hablar de salud con mi
compañera Mari Romero sala mar un saludo
para usted Buenos días Ángela y bien hoy
vamos a hablar del salto de los virus de
animales a humanos pensamos que no es
algo frecuente pero estamos equivocados
estamos un poco equivocados es más
frecuente de lo que creemos
principalmente porque los que hemos
conocido son grandes crisis pero sucede
también a menor escala y de forma más
puntual empezamos abordando este tema
con un estudio publicado en el
internationals que estudió entre 2017 y
2020 un grupo de una población de casi
700 personas en una zona de Malasia
donde hay varios reservorios de animales
con coronavirus especialmente sarveco
virus que es un tipo de coronavirus Como
por ejemplo el sars-cov-2 como el covid
19 no el virus del cobi 1984 de todas
estas personas estudiadas tenían
anticuerpos contra algunos de estos
serveco virus es decir el 12% de estas
personas que vivían en esas zonas habían
entrado en contacto en algún momento con
alguno de Estos tipos de virus y su
sistema inmune había tenido que
responder no significa necesariamente
que se enfermaran por esta infección
además algunos de los factores con más
correlación digamos era que trabajaran
estas personas en Industrias extractivas
Como por ejemplo la madera o también
particularmente la extracción de guano
de murciélago que son los excrementos de
los murciélagos que se usa como
fertilizante o que se dedicaran a la
caza de animales salvajes de nuevo
especialmente murciélagos además como
dato era interesante eran virus que
nunca se habían detectado antes en
infecciones en humanos y entre ellos
está el rat g13 que es el principal
pariente del cómic 19 conocido hasta la
fecha qué otros ejemplos conocemos de
estos saltos de virus de animales a
humanos pues es el principal origen al
final de enfermedades emergentes y hay
múltiples ejemplos en el VIH también el
ébola o la gripe aviar que lo hemos
venido hablando esta semana el Kobe 19
Por cierto este estudio no refuerza
bastante la teoría del origen natural
del covid 19 volvemos a estos debates
como decíamos alguna vez cíclicamente
pero repasando los últimos años vemos
que hay algunos casos que se han
detectado por ejemplo en 2002 en 2003
hubo siete casos en Tailandia el más
grande fue en 2017 en Haití un brote de
coronavirus que se encontraba en los
perros y que infectó a 20 personas en
humanos y también en 2019 en Kenia hubo
tres casos de mers de esa ese virus
también que en un momento dado también
provocó un brote entre humanos un
pariente cercano digamos sin embargo que
es importante decir pues que no
necesariamente que sea más frecuente
significa que nos tengamos que preocupar
como estamos viendo de hecho es casi una
buena noticia que de tantos virus que
hay a nuestro alrededor vivimos rodeados
y habitados de virus sean tan pocos los
que terminan generando un impacto real
en la salud pública Así que como
decíamos las infecciones no suelen ser
muy significativas primero tenemos un
sistema inmune que precisamente su
trabajo es pues blindarnos de este tipo
de problemas y segundo normalmente estos
virus tienen dificultad en extenderse en
las especies que no son digamos su
principal Su zona de Confort Por decirlo
de alguna forma sin embargo es cierto
que saber este tipo de dinámicas nos
ayuda a saber dónde tenemos que estar
vigilantes para posibles riesgos en el
futuro y también nos Recuerda que la
interacción con estos animales por
ejemplo a raíz de actividades
extractivas como decíamos como la
minería ola deforestación también hacen
que sea más riesgoso que puedan suceder
futuras pandemias en los años próximos y
por eso siempre será bueno entender lo
que hay en nuestro entorno vamos a hacer
un cambio de tema madre se publicaron
nuevos datos sobre el cáncer en Europa y
la información es en algunos casos
sorprendente sí son las predicciones
para 2023 se publican cada año en los
oncology y la principal conclusión Es
que la tasa de mortalidad por el cáncer
en Europa está bajando está bajando de
132 muertes por cien mil habitantes en
hombres en 2018 a 123 en 2023 es una
reducción del 6,5% se reduce un poco
menos en las mujeres 3,7% Aunque la tasa
en general como vemos Ya es
relativamente más baja es importante
hacerlo en relación con la población
porque debido al crecimiento de la
población debido al envejecimiento
también de las personas el número
absoluto de muertes por cáncer está
creciendo pero cuando lo revisamos como
decíamos en relación con los habitantes
en ese sentido esta disminuyendo otras
otros datos interesantes del estudio si
nos vamos todavía un poco más lejos
desde 1989 decían que se han evitado 5,8
millones de muertes por cáncer una cifra
para celebrar pero también predicen que
en 2023 van a haber 1,2 millones de
muertos en toda la Unión Europea por
esta enfermedad son cifras pues
agridulces que nos recuerdan En todo
caso que siempre hay un margen de mejora
Pero además en algunos casos de cáncer
la tendencia que se ha detectado es
desgraciadamente positiva Exacto en
general todo va a la Baja como estábamos
viendo pero hay un par de casos en los
que esta tendencia aumenta revisamos las
cifras de la publicación para las
muertes por cáncer en mujeres
particularmente Y aunque vemos Que en
general de nuevo Hay una disminución en
cáncer de mama por ejemplo también en
leucemias en cáncer colorrectal hay dos
casos en los que la tasa aumenta es el
cáncer de páncreas y el cáncer también
de pulmón Aunque en el cáncer de pulmón
dejemos hacer un Matiz que también
estaba incluido en el estudio y es que
las tasas sí cayeron en los grupos más
jóvenes de mujeres No necesariamente en
los de mujeres más mayores esto nos
lleva a una conclusión y es que todo
esto tiene mucho que ver con el consumo
de tabaco estamos viendo las
consecuencias de que las mujeres en la
década de los 70 o en la década de los
80 empezarán a consumir tabaco como ya
llevaban décadas haciendo los hombres
pero también eso significa que estamos
viendo que estas medidas públicas de
control de intentar reducir el consumo
de tabaco están funcionando están
funcionando en los hombres donde hace
más años digamos que están enfocándose
estas políticas públicas y efectivamente
el cáncer de pulmón se está reduciendo y
está funcionando como decíamos en las
mujeres jóvenes No necesariamente en
esas que empezaron a fumar sino hace
décadas sino ahora está funcionando
todas estas políticas del tabaco al
final es uno de los factores prevenibles
factores de riesgo prevenibles más
grandes que tienen más impacto en las
tasas de cáncer en todo el mundo
Entonces es importante tener estos datos
para respaldar que al final todas estas
medidas de implementaciones para
intentar reducir el consumo de tabaco al
final Pues tiene un impacto positivo el
resto es responsabilidad de cada quien
gracias a usted Muchas gracias Ángela